so willkommen zur ersten Preisträgerin tatsächlich
und falls Friedrich Merz zuschaut bitte jetzt
nicht aufregen es war kein gender Sternchen sie
ist wirklich eine Preisträgerin also sie ist
wirklich eine sie und ich freue mich sehr ihr die
Glocke überreichen zu dürfen weil ich kenne sie
schon sehr lange ich habe sie 2007 kennengelernt
im Quatsch Comedy live Club da haben wir zusammen
gespielt und sie hat also tatsächlich so den
den Wechsel gemacht von Stand Up Comedy zum
politischen Kabarett bzw eigentlich muss man
bei ihr sagen dass sie gezeigt hat dass die
Grenzen fließend sind und Stoffe in Humor das
ist ja oft bei uns Komikerinnen und Komikern
so ist ihre Leidensgeschichte gewesen und
zwar war damals ihre Leidensgeschichte dass
sie angehende Sparkassen Angestellte gewesen
ist und ich werde nie vergessen Sie auf die
Bühne gegangen und hat gesagt jeden Tag wenn
sie in die Filiale gekommen ist hat sie sich
erinnert gefühlt an den Film sixtens hat sich
umgeschaut und gesagt ich sehe tote Menschen
den Witz habe ich immer zu Hause erzählt mein
Vater fand es nicht lustig der ist auch bei
der Sparkasse gewesen und Volker bist was hat
über sie gesagt sie vereint in ihrer Person
die drei großen Haar des Kabaretts Haltung Humor
und Hirn ich würde noch ein Haar hinzufügen Herz
das trägt sie nämlich am rechten Fleck und die
Jury sagt damit seid ihr die Jury eine Künstlerin
aus die mit einer klaren Haltung zur politischen
gesellschaftlichen relevanten Themen begeistert
und ihn mit leichtfüßiger Bissigkeit mann mann
mann mann mann mann mann mann mann mann mann mann
wollen Sie jetzt die ganze Begründung von der Jury
hier abhauen das immer noch nicht fertig deswegen
so eine Anmoderation für eine Preisträgerin
oder einen Preisträger muss wie sein knackig
kurz und schräg aber ist die Jury nehmen
Sie Ihr glücksche und sagen Sie ihr Leute
was die Preisträgerin in der Sparte Kabarett macht
das ist hat man so geht es dem lustig gewesen
Publikum liebespublikum die preisträge
des deutschen Kleinkunst der schwarze
Kabarett hier ist die wunderbar Mann [Applaus]
danke schön vielen dank vielen Dank
vielen vielen Dank ich freue mich sehr über diesen
Preis ich freue mich sehr heute Abend hier sein zu
dürfen wobei bis vor zwei Tagen war ich noch
im sonnigen Süden und da war auch schön also
was jetzt seht ihr jetzt kann ich ihre Gedanken
quasi greifen so moment mal wir befinden uns
mitten im Klimawandel und die Frau ist geflogen ja
ich bin geflogen und ich finde es jetzt auch nicht
so wahnsinnig schlimm also zumindest solange
es sich nur um ein bis zwei Langstreckenflüge
pro Jahr handelt ein bisschen flugschaum hat
natürlich noch niemanden geschadet erst recht
nicht dem Klima und von mir aus könnte man auch
Kurzstreckenflüge sowieso komplett verbieten nur
grundsätzlich muss man sagen der Einfluss unserer
individuellen Entscheidungen auf den Klimawandel
ist relativ gering verstehen Sie mich nicht
falsch das heißt nicht dass wir ab heute alle
als umweltschweine leben sollen natürlich nicht
es ist schon gut und wichtig dass wir auf die
Umwelt achten nur der Effekt ist halt nicht sehr
groß die Sache ich sage Ihnen wie es ist selbst
wenn wir in Europa ab heute sofort alle als vegane
Wanderer leben würden könnten wir allein dadurch
den Klimawandel nicht stoppen vegane Wanderer
klingt merkwürdig oder ich find wie so ein Zombie
Film Die Nacht der veganen Wanderer oh oh oh oh
wir wollen los sonst gibt's was auf die Nüsse
oder wie so eine perverse Sexhotline
perverse Sexhotline vegane Wanderer aus deiner
Umgebung sind heiß auf deine verdorbenen Früchte
sie gucken mich an nach dem Motto hör politisches
Kabarett habe ich mir anders vorgestellt ja ich
auch was soll ich machen ich kann als Diplom
Volkswirte nicht mal sagen hätte ich mal was
vernünftiges gelernt aber zurück zum Thema
warum sage ich hier dass der Einfluss unserer
individuellen Entscheidungen eher gering ist
wenn uns doch seit Jahrzehnten das genaue
Gegenteil erzählt wird ganz einfach weil das
was uns seit Jahrzehnten erzählt wird eine Lüge
ist der weitaus größte Teil der CO2-Emission
stammt aus Produktion und Energiegewinnung da
haben wir überhaupt gar keinen Einfluss drauf
es ist eine Lüge und wer hat diese Lüge in die
Welt gesetzt die Mineralölkonzerne aus
den USA sollte uns das zu denken geben
ja das sollte es warum erzählt man uns seit
Jahrzehnten diese Lüge erstens wird damit
die Gesellschaft gespalten denn wir sind ja
alle wahnsinnig beschäftigt damit kritisch
zu bereuen wie die Nachbarn sich benehmen fliegt
sie ständig auf Geschäftsreise fährt er mit dem
SUV zum Bioladen Haut Sie sich jeden Tag ein
Steak in die Pfanne und so spaltet man eine
Gesellschaft und die wieder erdinner also teile
und herrsche war schon bei den Römern ein sehr
beliebtes Motto für den macht Erhalt und zweitens
wird auf diese Art ganz wunderbar davon abgelenkt
dass nur die globale Politik das Problem lösen
kann es ist so wenn wir den Klimawandel stoppen
wollen dann müssen sie sich alle Länder
einig sein ich habe so ein gutes Gefühl
aber jetzt muss man auch sagen der Klimawandel
ist auch selber schuld dass er von der Politik
kaum beachtet wird oder er ist echt selber
schuld muss man mal ganz klar sagen wissen Sie
warum weil der Klimawandel ein ganz beschissenes
Timing an den Tag gelegt hat beschissenes Timing
ist schlechter konnte man es nicht machen denn der
Klimawandel zeichnete sich ja so ungefähr Ende der
80er Jahre ab also genau dann als der ungehemmte
Kapitalismus sein weltweiten Siegeszug angetreten
hat auch durch den Zusammenbruch der DDR ja manche
haben schon immer gesagt der Ossi ist schuld
kennen Sie diesen schönen alten DDR Witz sagt
sie haben wir morgen soll Sonne geben
sagt er stelle ich mich nicht wieder an
durch den Zusammenbruch des Kommunismus hatte
Kapitalismus den Sieg davon getragen also man
darf sich ja jetzt auch nicht beschweren
wenn man Kapitalismus Kritik übt dann
heißt es sofort ja geh doch nach drüben aber
drüben gibt's doch gar nicht mehr ja siehste
ich persönlich glaube ja das mit dem Sieg
des Kapitalismus das sieht nur vorübergehend
so aus denn wenn wir Menschen ausgestorben sind
dann kommt der Kommunismus um die Ecke und sagt
gewonnen das Überlebensprinzip der Natur ist
nämlich kommunistische Kooperation und nicht
kapitalistischer Wettbewerb aber für uns ist
Kapitalismus Wettbewerb Konkurrenz die einzige
Wirtschafts- und Lebensform die wir uns noch
vorstellen können wir wollen ja auch alle nicht
mehr genussvoll Leben sondern effizient ne jeder
stellt seinen Körper für den Kampf im Wettbewerb
Sinnlichkeit ist verpönt ja und wo Sinnlichkeit
verpönt ist da gilt Emotionslosigkeit mittlerweile
als Zeichen von Qualität und Kompetenz ja
wir sind soweit Emotionslosigkeit gilt als
Zeichen von Qualität und Kompetenz anders lässt
sich der Erfolg von Olaf Scholz nicht erklären
erinnern Sie sich an die letzten Herbst da
wurde bei Madame Tussaud seine Wachsfigur
eingeweiht der Kanzler war natürlich auch
da da ist es zu einer Verwechslung gekommen
sie ahnen schon der Kanzler
ist im Museum geblieben
die Puppe haben sie mit ins Parlament genommen
es ist dann auch doch aufgefallen ja ja also
nicht im Museum der Scholz dass ich benommen
wie immer kein Problem im Parlament hat man es
gemerkt jetzt nicht wegen der Mimik nee nee
aber die Puppe hatte das bessere Gedächtnis
sehen Sie ich kann das doch mit dem klassischen
Kabarett dieses aus dem Fernsehen [Applaus]
unsere Verteidigungsministerin Christine Lambrecht
musste ja zurücktreten weil sie ein peinliches
Video gepostet hatte sie erinnern sich schlechte
Wort weil Silvester Böller im Hintergrund und
dann hat er auch noch der Wind ihre Haare Zert
und Entschuldigung geht echt gar nicht und ja
hätte die Frau Verteidigungsministerin besser
Mann Helm getragen die Bundeswehr hat ja keine
sehen Sie ich kann das aber ich will das nicht
nein das überlasse ich doch lieber den Jungs
komm mal lieber zurück zum inhaltlichen ich
glaube das Hauptproblem am Klimawandel ist
dass der Mensch sich nicht als Teil der Natur
empfindet sondern als Krone der Schöpfung ja
steht ja auch in der Bibel drin oder gehe hin
und macht die die Welt untertan jetzt bin ich
schon fast wieder bei den veganen wandern also
gehe hin und mach dir die Welt untertan das heißt
der Mensch erlebt sich als Krone der Schöpfung
und nicht als Teil der Natur und schon gar nicht
als Teil der Natur von der er auch noch abhängig
ist soweit kommt noch oder so erlebt der Mensch
sich und das ist glaube ich auch der Knackpunkt
beim Umbau zu den erneuerbaren Energien da gibt
es tief sitzende unbewusste Widerstände denn die
erneuerbaren Energien die können wir zwar nutzen
aber nicht besitzen das heißt die erneuerbaren
Energien zwingen uns drüber nachzudenken wann
Sonne scheint wann Wind weht wann Flüsse eine
Strömung haben die erneuerbaren Energien erinnern
uns daran dass wir von der Natur abhängig
sind entschuldigen wer will denn sowas wissen
und das ist ja auch das tolle an den fossilen
Energie oder die fossilen Energien ah das ist
super die kann man nämlich besitzen da kann man
sagen so das sind meine das sind meine die Grab
habe ich auswandern ich will dann kann ich auch
sinnlos ganze Dörfer Weg Banger egal das sind
meine die habe ich auswendig will und dann
verbrenne ich die Uhr ich habe Feuer gemacht
da fühlt Mensch sich überlegen aber es ist
wie es ist wenn wir den Klimawandel wirklich
stoppen wollen müssen wir das fossile Zeitalter
beenden und zwar so schnell wie möglich und
vor allen Dingen müssen wir weg von diesem
das Wachstum des Bruttoinlandsprodukts ist
der wichtigste Faktor für alles überhaupt ja
das kam aus diesem Herzen Danke dafür es ist
der US-Ökonomen hat mal gesagt wer in einer
stofflich begrenzten Welt an permanentes Wachstum
glaubt ist entweder ein Idiot oder ein Ökonom
ja ich bin quasi die Blumen aber ich habe ja den
Absprung geschafft also wenn wir den Klimawandel
stoppen wollen müssen wir das fossile Zeitalter
beenden wir müssen weg vom wachstumspostular wir
brauchen mehr Steuer für Reiche wir brauchen mehr
Umverteilung und vor allen Dingen mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit weil ohne die wird das alles
nichts also wenn wir den Klimawandel stoppen
wollen müssen wir also eigentlich genau das
machen was die politische linken seit Jahrzehnten
fordern also wenn wir jetzt an dem Punkt gekommen
sind wo wir feststellen dass die politische
linken eigentlich schon immer recht gehabt
hatten ja dann kann an der ganzen Geschichte vom
Klimawandel doch irgendwas nicht stimmen oder
wichtig ist doch dass wir trotz allem
unsere Lebensfreude bewahren ich werde
das auch immer wieder gefragt kann man in
diesen Zeiten überhaupt noch Kabarett machen
ja natürlich natürlich müssen wir weiter uns
amüsieren wichtig ist dass man die Lebensfreude
bewahrt und das können wir uns von den Kindern
abgucken diese kindliche Lebensfreude gucken
Sie mal Kinder die freuen sich über jeden Tag
die freuen sich schon wenn man kack sagt viele
haben die fünf Minuten Spaß dran ja und wir
Erwachsenen wir haben das verlernt weil wir
ständig damit beschäftigt sind möglich Kompetenz
und seriös rüber zu kommen aber man kann sich
diese kindliche Lebensfreude wieder beibringen
das geht ganz einfach sie können dafür auch in
Keller gehen wenn Sie wollen ja Sie können
das alleine zu Hause üben also wenn sie von
einem Zimmer ins andere gehen wenn sie um
die Ecke gehen sagen sie einfach ganz laut
merken Sie wie das gute Laune macht wenn man sagt
ist man automatisch gut gelaunt und wenn Sie das
einmal drauf war machen sie das automatisch ja
die Bahn fährt um die Ecke der Aufzug fährt los
wissen Sie was wir machen das jetzt
einmal zusammen wir sind hier unter
uns ja kriegt ja keiner mit auf drei machen
wir einmal zusammen alle zusammen hui 3 2
1 Zoll man soll aufhören wenn es am
schönsten ist danke schön [Applaus]